[Music]
can i snaggle liquid death
so what's up with this robot dog army
this is actually horrifying did you see
this no
dude what the [ __ ] holy damn damn they
get those those bars these sex dolls
they got that arch yeah that's what i
was looking at that's a dog dude
that's a that's a canine that's a
machine it's a robot don't [ __ ]
personify a
a series of servos and plastic run it
again let me see that arch
look at that damn no no no look at that
wait wait
[Music]
that ass is in the air dawg these things
are not gonna amount to anything more
than [ __ ]
like
delivery robots
you don't think it's a little bit scary
they're pretty agile oh dude that'd be
sick get a boston dynamics robot
and put like a cake a cake worth like a
birthday worth of roman candles pointed
up light them all and just send it off
yeah
yeah yeah
i i'll believe these are scary when
someone goes through there and starts
kicking them over and
you know if i see like they have like
crazy balance and all that [ __ ] that's
when i'll be scared and they like start
to fight back a little bit yeah yeah
that's when i'll be like okay okay
yeah yeah if it stands up on its hind
legs and then a machine gun comes out of
its chest yeah then i'm scared
[Laughter]
yeah i mean we've seen this we've seen
this
yeah let's let's let this [ __ ] ass go
see this
yeah it's scary because what it's sexy
hmm
yeah why why are they grinding
yeah that's what i'm saying just [ __ ]
um the other one's pushing the
one up against the wall yeah yeah it's
working on them
i like that you're demonstrating i think
they're well i mean yeah i figure that
helps the audience
better for you so if you're listening on
audio cody is grinding his ass into the
chair
no i'm actually up against the wall yeah
and he's uh replicating what these
boston dynamics robots are doing god
it'd be so funny if they made them do
like sexual [ __ ]
yeah it'd be so funny just like if one
yeah this is exactly what i was thinking
one got on a knees
the other one just started like
and all the engineers are like
like that's what it's going to be like
when they give head
no find the find the video of the robot
no that that [ __ ] um mobile like that
uh
uh ostrich segway thing that thing is
that's scary
what the [ __ ] is that that is scary
ostrich segway that [ __ ] is horrifying
bro why are you scared by that because
that to me that to me is a transformer
it's like my trash can undid itself and
is moving around see that one to me is
sexy
yeah it is your basketball hoop
like balls in my mouth
will not just
that one's sexy to you because it's got
a big block ass
yeah i love that huge weight yeah yeah
that gigantic block butt see that
that is scary yeah that is scary dude
nah
yeah i'm tense man
like the other ones are like dancing the
that one
the ostrich is thinking about like
running over children like that that
that motion
it's his it's butt winking
look at that look at that look at that
look at that
that is
that is haunting actually yeah
that is haunting 824 can make a whole
movie about that thing yeah just driving
through the street yeah every time we
cross frame i'd go yeah get it out god
get it out
oh
oh i hate it i hate it too
big sexy ass
god damn
cody of boston dynamics just humping the
[ __ ] out of that thing
yeah show me that ostrich thing again
i need she's mine i need her
do a fortnite dance please
it's just one of them that's so cool
they spent like years and years of
engineering expertise to just make them
annoying
my god dude
i want someone to come in and just shoot
one of these yeah
in the middle of it
they're all breaking it down and
somebody comes in with a shotgun and
just
bro
they did all that just to recreate a
wedding like after party yeah yeah
just left to the left to the left yeah
right i said it right now flink
wait is this okay now
nah see no no no i'm not i'm not worried
yeah
no
let this do itself
why do you just smack it
i know
this isn't real right this is fake oh my
god
bro rewind it rewind it
kicked him over dude
dude
this is so funny this is so funny
boss town dynamics dude
[Laughter]
this is so good
this is so good this is
if you're listening on audio it's like
this parody of boston dynamics
and they're like got this robot that
they're just kicking the [ __ ] out of
they're just beating the [ __ ] out of it
and it's just like trippy pose hell yeah
t-pose
yo there's gonna
yeah they abuse the [ __ ] out of these
things it's so funny damn damn just
making him kill a dog
they're making him kill the robot dog
awesome
this is my humor yeah
you better shoot that [ __ ] dog
no
oh my god
[Laughter]
oh he saves the dog he leaves
[ __ ] this is so good boss town dynamics
go watch who made it though
oh corridor made this [ __ ] got it
[ __ ] wow
how recent is that about a year
yeah i would imagine a year or two ago
i don't think i've seen any other
corridor digital stuff oh you definitely
have man have i willy wonka rated r was
theirs we watched that oh yeah yeah that
was yeah corridor makes insanely good
[ __ ]
are they
oh yeah yeah yeah
what's freddy doing now you want this
still
he was trying to break into like
traditional hollywood for actually a
long time
i watched him do a podcast where he
talked about it and um
it's actually an interesting thing
because i feel like freddie
was the unfortunately
the first like wave of content creator
trying to break into hollywood
and when he was trying to do it
he said the only thing he kept running
into were executives being like oh you
make stuff for youtube yeah that's that
thing my kid watches yeah that was like
the feedback he got all the time and
this was also like
before you could make a [ __ ] ton of
money doing it yes
yeah like
his productions cost a lot
so he was probably like breaking even
yep